to rebuild business we called for a
national
investment bank and i welcome the
announcement of a new uk
infrastructure bank having lost valuable
years since the green investment bank
was sold off now the chancellor must
boost
its firepower and he must deliver on his
department's responsibility
for the drive to net zero we've known
since the stern reports that the climate
crisis
is the biggest long-term threat to our
economy
yet far too often this spending review
locks us into a path
that will make the transition to net
zero harder
not easier locking our economy out of
the green
jobs of the future to rebuild business
the chancellor also needs to listen to
business
we're less than a week from the end of
the lockdown yet we've heard nothing
about whether extra support will be
provided through the additional
restriction support grant
for areas subject once again to tough
restrictions
and the chancellor still threatening
employers with an increased contribution
to furlough in january at the worst
possible time
for increasing and building confidence